hello and welcome back to the road mm
it's always my name is Caleb Denby and I
will be your driver on this journey
today I was going over some games from
the Tata Steel masters tournament that
is going on right now and there were a
few that that caught my eye when I was
trying to think of a theme for tonight's
class and so that theme I wanted to talk
about is hooks in chess
does anybody know what a hook is off the
top of their head no nobody knows what a
hook is all right
well will will see some very concrete
examples of what a hook is and how to
really use it to your advantage here in
tonight's class basically what it is is
when the pawns are on the seventh rank
it's hard to get at them this is just
obviously nonsense but you can see
whenever a pawn reaches a square or it
can attack another pawn and tough
shaoling you often try to do this to
open files later in the game to launch
an attack but when the pawns are all in
the seventh rank and they can quite
often just step forward
kind of like dodging dodging the pawn
and keeping the files closed and so what
a hook is is when a player commits to
moving upon off of the seventh rank for
example with the move like g6 now after
h5 g5 is a lot less easy to play than
the Move g6 because you're stepping away
from your other pawns protection so
quite often players will use any puns
that move forward as a hook something to
grab on to to open up files and so we're
gonna see how that actually looks in
practical games and how in this case
Fabiana Keira wanna used it to his
advantage against ali reza firoozeh
so without further ado let's see the
game it started off in the Kings Indian
defense with Knight c3 Bishop g7 efore
d6
and H 3 so H 3 is kind of a sideline for
for white but it's it's a pretty
ambitious one the idea is quite often in
the King's Indian black castles King
side and tries to push through with this
move f5 to gain some Kings side space
and h3 is very early on taking control
of the g4 square and hinting at the fact
that white might want to play G for
himself taking away this f5 option or at
least making a little more difficult
that being said black still gets castle
might place Bishop e3 and black has
tried a few things here
'if i didn't c5 are both pretty common
lines here for black but furusho chose a
little bit of a sideline it shows knight
c6 and this is really committing to a to
the small center idea where this move is
daring white to take all over the
central space in the hopes that later on
firoozeh is going to be able to attack
the center it's going to be a little
overextended and you really see this
with the next couple moves that happen
knight c6 is begging for d5 to be played
kicking this tonight away from its
natural home on c6 and Fabi does not shy
away from it d5 is played
now this Knight steps into e5 she
doesn't look like a bad square at all it
attacks the c4 pawn it looks at this d3
square but of course again it's begging
to be kicked away by this move f4 which
Fabi also does not shy away from and now
after Knight edie 7 Fabi fully commits
to this idea and plays g4 to continue so
you see in this opening here black has
moved this Knight around just a bit
wasted some time in return for this
white has a massive center and some
space on the Kings side as well and now
the battle is going to be confusion try
to prove that these pawns and squares
are going to be a little bit weak or
will Fabi use this space to to get it
get an advantage of course with a center
this imposing you can't let it sit for
just two for too long so firoozeh
immediately plays c6 already starting to
chip away
this Center Fabi continues development
of Knight f3 we see C takes d5 and C
takes d5
now this Bishop is still undeveloped so
black continues with b6 we have Knight
d4 aiming at this new weakness that has
just been created and now Knight c5 and
you can start to see how ferocious play
is is coming together here
both of these Knights are aimed at this
efore pawn and a common way to defend it
in the King's Indian would be would be
to play a move like f3 obviously the F
pawn has been advanced and this is what
we mean when we say squares have been
weakened by a 5 e grabbing so much space
so because the F pawn can't defend efore
anymore Bobby simply brings the Queen
out to do this job instead this Bishop
comes out to the b7 Square getting off
the back rank clearing the way for a
rook to come to the C file we see g5 and
now there is actually a little bit of a
tactic here that is played rather than
retreat this night version realizes he
needs to do something about this Center
and so he actually captures on e4 and
after Knight takes e4 the point of the
tactic is Bishop takes d5 pinning the
knight to the the major pieces for for
white here however of course it's not
quite so simple what seems like the move
for ax for white to get out of this pin
what resource does does white actually
have here
there's really only one one way to play
here
so just to go back to the basics of pens
this night can't move because the bishop
will capture the Queen but if you move
this night and create a threat of
greater value than the Queen then the
bishop does not have time to capture so
how can we create a threat of greater
value by moving this Knight
yeah Knight f6 check is exactly right
the bishop can't capture the Queen
because it breaks the laws of chess and
firoozeh follows the laws of chess so he
captures this knight and now white can
actually capture on d5 and for the
moment Fabi is up a full piece just one
full piece but bruges is going to get
some some pretty nasty compensation for
it so we see first rook e8 hits this
Bishop on e3 so Fabi plays Knight C to F
takes G v Queen side castles and now G
takes f 4 and this is quite a bit quite
a lot of pawns that fridge has gotten
for the piece here and so he has some
compensation and I wanted to talk about
the way fridge' actually has played thus
far because it's actually been a pretty
well played game up to this point when
you play an opening like the one that
firoozeh did where you see pawns on d5
efore g4 and f4 you can't really play
nonchalantly or else eventually you will
get kind of rolled over so the freezer
recognize this I mean be played this
piece sacrifice which many many players
would shy away from but it really is
necessary when you play an opening like
this if you can't find a way to break
down the center you really are just
gonna get rolled over by the space the
pawns are gonna continue pushing the
white pieces are gonna be more active
and so you do have to play kind of crazy
lines like this when the position calls
for it with that in mind though the game
continued Bishop d4 Bishop takes d4
Queen takes d4 this Knight comes to e6
now white could capture this pawn if you
wanted but sometimes it's better to keep
some pieces on especially in a
this position I think the Queen's kind
of favored white because why it's gonna
try to launch an attack on this Kings
side eventually we see Queen d2 this
Queen comes to f6 Fabi takes the time to
play King b1 simply improving these
Kings position now Rick I see it Bishop
b5 finally developing this bishop and
gaining some time on this rook rook 88
night before and now d5 and once again
firoozeh is playing quite well he's
keeping pace with Fabi in a wildly
imbalanced position so a little side
note on on playing down a piece when you
have a lot of puns for compensation
exact this is exactly what you want to
do it's not enough to simply hold on to
the pawns and claim that they're enough
compensation for the piece here freesia
actually has four pawns for the piece
but those pawns only really count if
they start moving down the board and so
that's what he's doing here with this
deep on he's starting to move it down
the board once again Fabi could capture
this pawn but then the files start to
open up for the black rooks this Queen
is a little bit awkwardly placed and the
activity that black would get in return
for it really isn't worth it here so
he's just making his deep on his deep
pawns presence felt with this move d5
and then eventually we'll see after work
f1 and rook c5 and a for now d4 as well
the the further up the board this pawn
gets the more its its presence is kind
of felt it's a it's actually like a
player in the game it's not just like
currency you see players sometimes talk
about pawns like their currency like Oh
white is up +1 here that's like one pawn
and then he pays his pawn away for a
different advantage that's not really
how how playing with extra pawns works
that there are pieces and they should
kind of be used as such in this case
it's controlling some key squares and
threatening to take it even further down
the board getting closer closer to
queening 93 is White's choice blockading
this pawn on d4 we see rook f5
rook F 3 and so Fabi blockades all of
blacks pawns and now g5 and I want to
talk about this move a little bit so I
was just talking about how pawns needed
to be pushed down the board to make
their presence felt but especially with
the pawns in front of the King that's
when you have to be a little bit careful
so you might remember what I was talking
about at the beginning of this lecture
which was hooks and g5 is definitely
creating a hook so how can Fabi look to
take advantage of this not immediately
but maybe a little bit later down the
line what move in particular should
probably be looking at now in yeah
really both players yeah it's totally
right
h4 is always going to be something for
fusia to look out for and for Fabi to
try to take advantage of h4 trying to
open up files in front of this black
King to make his extra piece be be
useful
you know conversely you know we talked
about using the pawns getting them up
the board so their presence is known
with the extra piece it's sometimes
quite useful to launch an attack on the
Kings side try to get at the King
because that's where the piece is really
shine is when lines open up and you have
something to really attack so what's the
problem with h4 immediately what would
black play
yeah that's exactly right it's not a
very good hook if black can simply step
out of the way now this G file stays
closed and in fact these puns and tandem
together are going to be very very
strong
so h4 would actually be a huge mistake
immediately but with that in mind what
might be a better move to start creating
some threats of playing h4 yeah queen g2
or g1 these these are both great moves
um in the game Fabi chose Rick g1 and I
think I like this one a little bit
better than Queen g2 but yeah Queen g2
is a great idea as well I think it's a
perfectly good move but we'll stick with
Rick g1 and now fabi's threat is kind of
obvious with this knowledge in mind
right so Fabi wants to play h4 what do
you think the best way for black to
respond to this threat is what can a
what can black do
so ideally black would want to keep the
files closed somehow in the previous
position he did that by planning g4 and
so is there any way we can kind of renew
this threat or this resource of playing
g4
and it is
so I'll give you a little hints it'd
help if we had some piece that was able
to control this square right so can we
defend this square in preparation for
the move age four yeah Age 5 is exactly
right and once again this comes back to
making the presence of your pawns kind
of kind of known you're using this pawn
not as currency not as something to say
I have one pawn this is good this is one
of my four pawns for the piece that
means I'm doing okay you're using it as
a useful useful defender and so now h4
would once again be a terrible mistake
because g4 would come with with a lot of
force and this pawn might even get get
captured and really this this was
freesias one and only serious mistake in
this game up until this point he had
been playing very very well and but
unfortunately for him Bobby had also
been playing very very well and it just
so happened that Frazier made the first
mistake he played the move King f8 and
now after h4 fabi's hook is is kind of
successful it would be a huge mistake
now to take on h4 because this open g
file would be very very very problematic
for for black and as well as the fact
that you've removed the defender of this
F pawn is going to be a big deal as well
in fact simply rook g4 might immediately
be picking up this pawn and then these
remaining pawns
while there are a lot of them they're
not exactly the most stable they should
be able to be picked up by the remaining
white pieces so instead of trying to
capture this pawn black plays h6 but the
hook is here Bobby still has a chance to
open the file and he does so immediately
with h6 g5 + H takes g5 and this is the
the power of a hook in chess and
latching on to the hook is in this
position the white major pieces have no
way of getting into the Kings side and
compared to this position there's now
this Avenue to to invade the black camp
and Fabi immediately tries to take
advantage of it with this move rook
age three and so now you can imagine the
white pieces starting to get at this get
at this black King if black isn't
careful
friesan continued with f3 trying to push
this pawn further trying to make this
pawn more relevant than the threats on
the Kings side Fabi actually continuous
with Bishop c4 I now this night which
was defending this this Jeep on note
without the pawn on age seven age six
now is not an available move to defend
this pawn so this is a little bit more
of a weakness kingi seven freesia tries
to escape from the Kings side we see
Bishop takes c6 and now actually King
takes c6 and here maybe freesia missed
his chance
maybe f2 was a little bit of a better
move to try and uncoordinated capturing
this Bishop but ok we see King takes c6
and now after Queen h2 this Queen is
eyeing some very important squares
around this King as well as confirming
fabi's control over this open file here
and the the end is really near for
firoozeh the game did continue with f2
rook F 1 King d7 this threat comes in to
h6 no and you see this open file is
really what what's a sealed for uses
fate Queen e7 this turret captures f2
and now that cruises extra pawns are
starting to fall the extra night is as
well worth it King c8 a 5 ends kind of
similarly to the Kings side we see Fabi
using yet another hook to break down
this defensive structure in this case
though freesia does capture and now we
see Queen c2 check King b8 night c5 and
with this pawn removed Knight c5 is now
coming in with with pretty strong
effects or if d6 we see your KJ check
rook d8 Queen b3 check King c7 and with
this Knight now in tandem with the Queen
the King comes to
d6 and after Rick's f6 and 94 frisia
felt it was time to resign this game the
king is just going to get trapped and
after a move like King e6 they're simply
rook f6 and there's no way to stay in
contact with this Queen and this endgame
is pretty much pretty much hopeless and
so that was the end of the game for
firoozeh and I don't want to downplay
how well freesia was playing up until
this point this sacrifice on on e4 was
actually quite nice for fusion getting
all these pawns in return for this this
Knight blowing up the white center was
all very very good good ideas but then
the fact is Fabi played with a lot of
precision precision in this game and
while firoozeh was making his his pawns
useful this moved g5 is kind of the
start of things starting the tip-in
fabi's favor and then after King f8 this
is when h4 really opened up the position
in fabi's favour and he converted kind
of flawlessly so once again always be
aware of these hooks that you create and
how your opponent can take advantage of
them
so definitely h5 was the wafer Yugi
should have played here getting ready to
counter the move h4 with the move g4
when everything would be looking quite
well for for black any questions on this
game I kind of went through a lot of the
the opening up till move like 20 or so
pretty quickly but the main point I
wanted to talk about was was this g5 and
h4 kind of maneuver but say and any
questions about anything that happened
there
so so yeah Bobby wasn't really
threatening to to capture f4 but but
maybe after move wreck f1 he would be g5
itself I don't think is actually a bad
move after rook g1 and h5 you can
imagine somewhere down the road with
some more preparatory moves let's let's
say Bobby waste some time here not that
you would I'm not even sure these are
good moves but let's say this Rick gets
to g8 somehow right and then all of a
sudden the move g4 starts to look a lot
more appealing after takes takes with
these two pawns together this is
actually like a winning attempt for
black I gave like a lot of time there
and obviously that that wouldn't happen
in this manner in the game but with the
move h5 and g4 Persia would be really
creating some serious threats on the
Kings side so g5 is nice and the fact
that it's it's kind of playing for a win
but it does come with some risks which
is important to keep in mind any other
questions
yeah I think black could play h5 here if
you wanted but it doesn't make as much
sense without g5 because I'm what you're
doing is controlling g4 and that really
isn't necessary unless h4 is is coming
on the board but probably Bobby would
would play a move like maybe still Rick
to u1 maybe this move Bishop c4 that he
played in the game would also be his his
response but yeah I'm not sure the order
was super important but but g5 first
kind of makes sense you want to defend
this pawn and you want to start to
create some threats of expanding further
okay anything else before we move on all
right now I want to take a look at we
see we've seen the the number two in the
world use hooks to his advantage in this
tournament let's see what the number one
in the world can do Magnus Carlsen this
was his game against Vladislav Kovalev
also from the Tata Steel masters I
believe also in in round
but let's see how this game wins we have
d4 once again Knight of 6 c4 e6 Knight
f3 d5 Knight c3 Bishop e7 so just a a q
GD Queens game and declines Bishop g5
castles III h6
Bishop f4 and now c5 and in this type of
position worth so much tension in the
center sometimes both players let it sit
for a while but almost always someone
caves and starts capturing these pawns
in this case white does it immediately
with D takes e5 we see Bishop takes c5
and now a3 and we'll see why it's idea
here and just a couple notes we see
knight c6 Queen c2 and now Knight h5 is
Black's opening choice here
a bishop comes to g3 and now if black
waste any more time
I think White's idea is to play this
move b4 and gain a lot of space here on
the Queen side which moves like B 4 and
C 5 as well as ideas of taking on d5 as
well so because of some of this black
simply captures on D on c4 here as well
Bishop takes Bishop comes back to e7
stepping out of B for stepping out of
the the Queen's line-of-sight this
Bishop actually drops back to a2 we see
a6 rook d1 hitting the Queen Queen i5
and now a very annoying move by Magnus
Bishop b1 so this was his idea with
bringing the bishop back to a 2 so you
wanted to reroute behind this Queen and
really make some threats of giving
checkmate so off the top of your head
how would you respond to this with black
you have a few options yeah
g6 is a very very natural move it's it's
the most natural move to kind of stop
this threat and I'm not totally sure
what made
Kovalev shy away from this
maybe it was simply he was feeling a
little bit more ambitious than g6
obviously this move comes with some
weaknesses it weakens the f6 square in
the h6 square but perhaps this Bishop
could snuggle itself in nicely on on g7
probably part of the issue for kovalev
is that he wanted to I'll just play her
in to move here he probably wanted to
capture this bishop and he might have
been a little bit wary of leaving this H
pawn behind with the opening of the H
file coming coming in soon because of
that he played the move f5 but actually
g6 was was simply better this is keeping
things a little bit more compact and
it's not giving white such a powerful
hook which we'll see later in the game
so after f5 with the theme of the
lecture being hooks how can we take
advantage of this move at a later date
not immediately which move yet actually
e4 and we'll see another way to take
advantage of it later in the game too
which is g4 exactly which could be
either this H pawn come to g4 or our
initial G pawn and this is actually
exactly what what Magnus does he just
uses this pawn to his advantage and
breaks open the the center with pretty
devastating effect alright welcome so
the game continued white went ahead and
got castled black now captures this
bishop we see H takes Bishop f6 and then
Magnus actually doesn't waste any time
here he breaks up in the position with
either g4 or e4 which one do you think
it was here
any guesses
efore was this choice can I ask why you
liked efore over g4
yeah that's that that's pretty far yeah
II for simply opens up so both moves are
aimed opening up the diagonal we can say
that as well as opening up this efore
square if black were to capture but the
movie for also kind of opens up this
this efile as well and this is something
that Magnus probably wanted to to use to
his advantages as well you can imagine
let's say if we took like this you see
this epon is still kind of in the way it
keeps keeps things kind of boxed out for
for Magnus
so e4 was actually his choice I thought
you might be tempted to say g4 because
you're fixing your pawn structure
obviously black really shouldn't take
and so there might be a captures and now
your pawn structure looks a little bit
better but in fact I think it's efore
that is that is actually better and
that's something to keep in mind in your
games in many types of positions just
because a pawn is doubled doesn't make
it necessarily worse than then another
pawn and so this G pawn here is actually
quite useful it is blocking any ideas
along this diagonal and it has a lot of
mobility to come to g4 whereas this pawn
on the e3 Square is kind of in the way
so efore was Magnus's choice we see
Bishop takes c3 of course white wants to
keep Queens on the board so he
recaptures with the pun and now after
Queen takes a three white continues with
this plan and takes on f5 opening up the
diagonal a little bit more now Magnus
wants to use this efile to his advantage
like we said so he plays Rick fe1 and
this is something that I really like
from from Magnus here perhaps the less
patient player would have just played g4
immediately but there's really no reason
to rush he simply improves all of his
people all of his pieces and then only
then continues with the plan
so Ricky won this Queen comes back to a
5 and now I've kind of given it away but
but what do you expect the next move to
be here
exactly g4 and so we kind of see a
double hook on this f5 square
Magnus uses this advanced pawn he hooks
onto it and uses it to open up diagonals
and files for all of his pieces and
that's how he gains activity and what
used to be a closed position so g4 says
move and Magnus is actually completely
crushing in this position black tried
Queen c7 of course you don't want to
take this Queen h7 is devastating so
Queen c7 Knight age 4
he puts even more pressure onto this
pawn ready to open things up g5 is Cove
lives attempt but after Knight takes f5
Magnus is simply winning upon and it's
going to be very very difficult for
black to deal with this f5 pawn of
course you can't let this night just sit
here it will move out of the way to
numerous squares and allow the pieces in
so Kovalev desperately tries to keep the
position closed by taking this night and
blockading this pawn trying to use
White's pawn against him but of course
this is not quite as solid as having you
know a member of your own army on the f5
square magnus plays ricky 6 trying to
break this blockade once again open up
the lines to get his pieces in rick a f8
magnus simply captures on f6 and plays
Bishop a to check after King f8 Queen d3
and you see Magnus eyeing some squares
to to invade here 95 is Koval F space
simply Queenie 4 rook d6 Queen B 4 pins
this rook and after King 7 there are
some tactics here that Magnus's that
Magnus use uses to simply win the game
f6 check is attempting to distract the
Queen the King so we can capture this
rook the King comes to d7 instead and
now rook e1 is a very nasty move from
Magnus Carlsen attacking this Knight and
if the knight were to move there is
ricky 7 check to look out for and if
this Knight were to come to a square
like c6 i simply a move like queen g4
check and and f7 is going to be more
than enough with queening to follow or
rook e8 made a lot of lot of ways to win
for Magnus so rook e1 black went ahead
and captured this pawn which is probably
the best try defending this Knight but
Queen d4 check is a simple fork in the
game soon came to a conclusion with
black resigning in in this position so
once again it's the same idea as in the
first game on a little bit of a
different square the first game we saw
Cara Juana opening up the H file whose
advantage in this game
Magnus opened up actually quite a few
lines we'll say we opened up this
diagonal for his Bishop and Queen as
well as the e-file
for his rook and these two files this
file in this diagonal together are what
he used to gain activity for his pieces
any questions about about this one we
went through this one a little bit
faster
no questions alright so I'll just jump
back to this move here just for a little
recap once again black should have
played g6 here and while the g6 might
look to be a more weakening move at
first because this pawn on g7 does a
very nice job of protecting aged 6 and
from g6 dark squares start to look a
little bit weaker so you might think
well f5 gives up these squares but these
squares are not so easily attacked this
is kind of the trap of thinking you can
fall into when deciding between moves
like f5 and g6 but a huge downside to f5
is when you move upon two squares
becomes a much better hook for your
opponent's pieces and so moves like
efore and g4 become very very hard to
stop and this is really an idea to look
for whenever your opponent advances upon
especially in front of his King to this
this fifth rank will say with that of
Mines
that about does it for Carlson's game
for game number three of the night I
wanted to look at Daniel
dubov against the lattice of arts and
Artemyev
we'll see how hooks came into play in
this opening as well we have E 4 C 6 d 4
D 5 e 5
I should be' 5 it's just a caro-kann
advanced h4 h5 this is very topical
these days players love playing this h4
move forcing h5 early from black
creating some weaknesses and I'll see if
you guys can guess where's the hook
already there's a hook somewhere to look
for it's not a trick question
which one ah so you're looking from the
black point of view which is not a bad
thing to look for f6 it's kind of you
know keeping an inline with the idea of
the hook f6 when you're attacking upon
that's so far advanced though this is
more about just attacking the pawn
itself attacking the centre itself
rather than trying so much to open files
although f6 can often open the F file
for for blacks pieces as well so you're
on the right track there g5 as well but
in this case white has more central
space so he's better equipped to handle
with on opening up of the king's side so
with that of Mines where's the hook for
white I'll say ah ok so yes c4 but the
move I'm looking for is actually this
this H pawn way down the road will see
that this H pawn being forced to h5
actually becomes relevant so this move
g4 is something to look out for and this
is a point I wanted to make about about
hooks quite early on in this game
because from a distance you don't really
see h5 ever you don't see the g4 being a
problem here right this square is well
defended even Knight h6 can defends this
g4 square again you don't really see it
being a problem from from this position
but the fact is once you put this pawn
here that's always going to be a threat
for white it's always going to be
something you have to keep track of and
we'll see that maybe eventually black
loses sight of this
and g4 becomes very relevant with that
in mind though you did mention c4 which
is very relevant hook in this position
as well you're trying to open up the
center as quickly as possible at the
expense of leaving your pieces
undeveloped for a little bit longer
black continues with this movie 6 we see
Knight c3 black develops with Bishop e7
I don't believe this is actually the
most common way of playing usually you
see something like 97 or 97 although I
believe there was already a very very
nasty game played earlier in this
tournament where I'm not sure if in
Artemyev as black but someone got
crushed by firoozeh and in this line
with 97 so perhaps looking for a change
of pace he plays the sidelines Bishop e7
here white simply continues with C takes
d5 and C takes d5 and so in this case
well it will call to hook on d5 the hook
was used to open up this this C file but
it's not quite the game-changer that
that the opening of the e-file and the
diagonal was was last game white
continues very naturally with Bishop d3
Bishop takes d3 Queen takes d3 white is
getting developed we see knight c6
Knight f3 Knight h6 you can imagine
maybe black could capture this pawn but
opening up this h-file usually isn't in
a in Black's best interest so instead we
see 96 and now after Knight f3 this this
pawn is defended Knight h6 and white
actually makes the decision to capture
this Knight giving away or taking away
blacks castling rights and forcing was
rook to slightly unnatural Square rook
c1 King f8 because castling is legal g3
defends this pawn forever we see g6
giving this King a square to come to
both sides nearing the end of their
development we see castles and King g7
and now Knight a4 and rook h8 so both
players have kind of gotten developed
and this is kind of the main position
will we'll see ourselves in here
so this is a pretty typical caro-kann
type type of structure and i wanted to
ask you guys if you could find what are
some natural ideas for for both sides
here where is the play early going to be
directed
where do you think
you know ideas
yeah there's there's no real way to
improve this this minor piece in
particular it is doing a really good job
though on e7 its guarding both of these
advancing squares for for the Knights so
it is serving an important purpose on e7
the pieces that can really be improved
here
well for one White's already trying to
improve this night and for two it's it's
these major pieces right so with that in
mind where do these major pieces belong
in this position yeah there's only one
open file for the moment it's the C file
and so black should be trying to Kontest
the C file meanwhile White's trying to
improve this night and he'll look to
kind of dominate the C file before Black
has a chance to get there and we'll see
how both players go about this first of
all night c5 this Bishop captures and
like we said this bishop was actually
serving an important purpose so while
White's spent some time getting this
Knight to c5 now that this bishop is
missing it gives this Knight a little
bit more opportunity to improve itself
as well
so both players simply trying to improve
their pieces and for black that really
means getting these rooks to the C file
for white that might mean trying to do
something on the Kings side well also
kind of playing this this dangerous game
where you don't let black get the C file
and you try to advance on the Kings side
but really you're keeping an eye on the
C file so it's difficult to play these
positions with white and with black I
think it's a little bit simpler you
really just need to get on the C file
put some pressure here and that's how
you can find enough counter play so
Queen d7 is black's choice a very
natural move preparing to bring her up
here we see rook F to c1 and simply rook
H to c8 and now after Queen c3 let me
double check here yeah what do you guys
think the best move is for four black
what could the best move be keeping in
mind what we were talking about
any ideas what moves coming to mind yeah
black would actually love to play b6 but
of course he doesn't quite have enough
support for this night here
yeah f6 would be a pretty substantial
mistake you don't want things to open up
on this side of the board you want to
focus the attention on this C file so
with that of Mines the best move for
black is to actually play this move 97
just already accepting some trades along
this file and trying to simplify things
a little bit and the reasoning for that
is that white is always going to have a
slight edge in terms of things opening
up on the kingside things open up on the
kingside whites edge is going to be this
strong pawn on e5 spawns going to create
a lot of threats around this King with
its control over f6 and its ability to
kind of keep this knight from supporting
the King side Oh too too too much and so
because there's this nagging threat of
things eventually opening on the Kings
side black would love to take off some
of these major pieces before things get
nasty so move like 97 is actually really
important probably the reason he shied
away from this as this move rook c7 but
in actuality this position I don't think
is too bad for for black at all this
Queen does get to this annoying c7
square but after move like Knight f5 for
example the black pieces are starting to
coordinate again and you can imagine
that while black has kind of conceded a
little bit on the C file his pieces are
now a little bit more free to get active
instead we see the move
a5 which I'm not a huge fan of by
pushing this pawn forward you are
creating kind of a weakness right this
is something you're gonna have to keep
an eye on now kind of for the rest of
the game
so we see a three from white trying to
keep this night out of the be Foursquare
one of the advantages of a five and now
a four from black and this is kind of
black trying to attempt to create some
winning chances I think he's he's taking
some space on the queenside at some risk
which isn't a horrible idea
now this night comes to be one hoping to
reroute itself and we'll see where to in
just a moment and now is kind of blacks
final chance here once again this move
Knight East seven is what should have
been played and if the move Rick's to
seven were to be played now even this
move Queen d8 could be played really
keeping all chances of white getting to
this this annoying seventh ranked kind
of negating those by keeping this pin
along the the C file instead though like
did something very very strange
and that was try to repeat moves played
Queen e7 and after this night comes back
to f3 Queen d7 giving white the chance
to kind of improve his position some
more and white does so at the move King
g2 and now a trick c7 black is
attempting to make some progress but we
see Queen c2 from white aiming a little
bit at these squares on the Kings side
now Queen d8 and this Queen actually
comes to d1 and who can spot what this
Queen on d1 is supporting indirectly for
the moment but very very directly soon
he's supporting g4 that's right and it's
been 30 some moves maybe I haven't been
keeping track no not quite 20 some moves
since h5 has been played but the the
fact is this g4 threat is is never going
away this skin so black really didn't
have time to sit back and do nothing in
this position he had to play a move like
97 which looks a little bit scary on the
surface but doing nothing isn't an
option here for black because white
always has this hook on h5 to open up
the position and that's exactly how this
game continued here we see the move rook
d7 from black the move Knight g5 from
white we move rook a6 now and everybody
knows White's next move right I hope
what is it
it's g4 and this is kind of devastating
actually for a for the black position
here due to some awkward maneuvering
black is actually totally vacated the C
file so all of whites pieces are
available to come in to join this attack
as as quickly as possible with the
opening up of this h-file
and because of that move H takes G would
be a pretty fatal mistake you still have
some time to bring this Queen over to
the Kings side but it's it's much too
slow so instead after g4 black tried
Queen h8 immediately
now why it wouldn't want to take this
and give the black Queen the opportunity
to come back into the game so instead we
see Queen f3 and this work comes to b6
trying to create some some counter play
but it's a little bit too late in here
there was some very funny business
involving the mover okay v but so we
don't need to go into all this by you
know removing this this Knight the sort
can come in and then some some annoying
things happen for black but white played
very very simply G takes h5 and now more
relevant than the opening of the G file
is
the distraction of this queen of course
black wouldn't want to capture back with
the G pawn because the rook come to g1
very quickly and that would be death for
the King so black is forced to capture
back with the Queen and yes it is nice
to have this file be half open but more
importantly this Queen has been drawn
away from the King and now after Queen
f6 check and King g8 once again this
move rook a 5 it's a little bit more
clear now why it works if Knight takes
and this is simply checkmate but this
comes into play and white is invading
along the back rank and all is kind of
falling apart black tries to give a
check after King f1 there's simply no
more checks the squares defended rook
her 98 was played rukka and black went
ahead and resigned here just a quick
note you can't play the mover k-6
because Rick takes a 6 and B takes a 6
and this night falls and it's all the
same problems so this is the final
position of the game where where black
went ahead and resigned and I really
like this game a lot for for dubov here
because he really took his time he let
black kind of kind of implode right
black got a little bit antsy and he
wasn't willing to accept this 97
allowing the white pieces into the
seventh rank but keeping things under
control instead Artemyev or artemyev
excuse me
simply didn't didn't do enough he didn't
sense the urgency of the position and
dubov sat back on this g4 idea until the
placement of the black pieces was
awkward enough for this opening up on
the Kings side to to kind of win the
game for him
with that in mind we're there any
questions on this game in particular
yeah
yeah so white was probably deciding what
to do here after 91 he might be hinting
at some F for ideas I'm not saying that
F 4 is a good move but maybe he's
pretending he's threatening this also
probably on his mind was the move Knight
D 3 and this night could come to f4 with
some sacrificial ideas or it could come
into a square like c5 or square like b4
to try and shake loose this Knight or or
attack this pawn but the fact is I think
just the specifics of the position this
knight on d3 doesn't make too much of a
difference here actually because if we
keep in mind let's say move like Queen
d7 after night before you're kind of
forcing black to play the move that he
should have been playing which is 97 and
to move like Knight f4 while it is
vaguely threatening it does work well in
tandem with a move like g4 I actually
would have liked this maneuver but I'm
not sure something clearly made a white
shy away from this perhaps that was even
this move g5 from black I might be
talking out of turn here but g5 might
have been might have been an idea for it
for black if this Knight strays too far
away but yeah sometimes you'll see these
these grandmasters repeat every now and
then but yeah King g2 and this maneuver
of the Queen back to d1 was was very
very nice for white to to open up this
Kings side any other questions
okay well with that in mind I think I'm
going to call the lecture here just a
quick review of everything we went over
the theme of today was was hooks and
these by the way are all games from the
Tata Steel masters tournament which is
still going on and I would recommend you
all check it out because it's a very
very interesting tournament to follow
but the theme of the lecture of course
is hooks which means you should always
be careful and always get excited when
you see a pond pushed to the
fifth-ranked like this it creates this
permanent idea of attacking this pond to
open up files it's very very powerful to
open up these lines at the moment of
your your choosing so with that in mind
thank you all for joining me for this
week's Road to 2000 as always my name is
Caleb Denby and I will see you in the
next episode
[Music]
you